sorry
i was just changing the baby's nappy
ever heard it's not that good hello
and welcome to ramsey in 10. i hope you
have a great weekend uh happy bank
holiday weekend
uh what an amazing day it's been out
there
um first of all i just want to say uh
thank you to all of you
in your thousands tuning in and coming
up with these incredible recipes
um i've got the magnificent three back
with me today for 10 minutes only to get
this amazing
video done um let me introduce you to
the crew first
the dop director photography there she
is
hello you always
do this what do you want me to say how
are you doing how are you doing
how was your weekend how was your
weekend
repeat after me i had the easiest
a-levels in the history of school
i have not i still have to do a little
work just not the exams
but you you've got your own level on
your marks i haven't got my a-level
yet you got something that i haven't got
um
how are you how's your day up for
breakfast anything else
oh my goodness me holly what is that
this is
truffle truffles um holes like we need
another dog that's our seventh dog
mine not yours dog number seven so we
have seven dogs
we have three cats daddy's lost your dap
obviously seven dogs three cats four
parrots five goldfish and in fact they
were called jaws one two three and four
and five
unfortunately lost two because i was
starving for some two weeks ago
where's my sous chef where is he where
is he there he
is he's oh no
he needs a haircut he needs a haircut
uh that's not too bad there is it's got
the old sort of the locks down locks the
lockdown locks it was pretty cool
right seriously i mean this house is
exactly babysitter two meter distance
with that shopping trolley
right let's go to bed uh excuse me it's
going to be hey good night
it's it's daytime troubles don't you
dare poop on the carpet man
just very quickly why do you call them
troubles because i like truffles
and his skin color is rare gotcha is
that chocolate truffles or elbow
truffles
white chocolate white chocolate right
okay
okay okay okay up here
right you're not allowed to tell me what
to do with the camera you stick to the
cooking okay but if i say pan down it
means pan down
please if i say pan down and just pan
down because you're missing the shop
right first of all
come on seriously congratulations
sir tom i mean how cool is that i mean
honestly
next week no doubt he'll be auditioning
for the new bond movie incredible
what an amazing legend raised over 40
million pounds
just by starting to walk in the back
garden that's an inspiration for
everybody
the nhs uh incredible i mean what an
amazing job again so thank you to all of
you
happy birthday weekend happy memorial
weekend in the us
and a big thanks to all of everyone
across that country that sort of
put their lives forward to get everybody
safe so what an amazing weekend
ready ten minutes sausage and mash
set the timer first of all turn your
pants on get the gas on hands-on
also ball the kettle okay if you bought
the kettle let the water boiling quickly
so when you cook the potatoes
it's done start the clock please three
two one
excellent now salt into the water okay
get that cup of boiling
top it up with boiling water so you
don't lose that boil and obviously when
you're up against it hand down please
right i'm gonna end this unless you stop
get those potatoes in
okay and make sure that water's boiling
now i've cut them super small okay why
have i cut them super small
please it's me now but depending how
much time you've got
take them down to the small die small
guys they'll put literally in four five
minutes large dies seven or eight
minutes but don't cut them too big
nicely salted water and don't fill the
pan up just cover the potatoes with
water
next sausages i've got amazing pork
sausage here okay
now a little touch of oil okay i'm gonna
start them off with a little
touch of olive oil just a little touch
okay no it's not it's not
it's the pan that's made start it in
sort of semi
lukewarm again bring up the temperature
now what are you laughing at
ladies and gentlemen and then take a
little cocktail stick okay
and just sort of lightly
tap them while you're laughing ladies
now i'm just saying prick
the sausage okay and that stops the
skins from bursting
okay now roll them around aromats
i'm talking about flavor get some garlic
okay from there
just crush the garlic put that in there
now
the secret here is to get a really nice
color on those sausages
i've got some garlic and some rosemary
now look
okay roll them around once you've got
the color on those sausages
okay from there
turn them around let the pan do the work
turn them around i want these sausages
nice and fragrant
pan down please turn down get your pan
on
back up the gas as it starts to get
color on there and put a bit of flush in
there
next your onion for the onion gravy i'm
going to use red onion
why it's so much more sweeter less
acidic
than the white onion and it gets really
nice and dark in terms of the
caramelization
slice the onion nice and fine now
tiny drizzle olive oil in there take
your onions
and open them up into the pan there you
go
look now flatten them out nicely
okay time please two minutes two minutes
thank you
girls you're all right today yeah we are
a quick pan down some of the ingredients
please
look at this i have some smoked salt
here okay
some dijon mustard vinegar lemon little
touch of stock in there okay
look how quick my water's boiling
already once the water starts boiling
come up and take a little bit out okay
and that way they'll cook even faster
now back to the sausages
look at the color on those sausages now
we go in with some butter
i've got a really nice flavor okay
on those sausages oh you're burning your
onions no they're not that's caramelized
please don't start that again please
that's not fair
right look pan down please i'm basting
with the garlic and the rosemary
and that butter is going to turn the
sausage really nice and fluffy
okay now look
if it splits turn it around it doesn't
matter okay
and look what you're laughing at
happening
touch more butter in there okay and then
from there they're gonna go in to the
other
now time please you have done
three minutes 40 seconds sausages in the
oven literally about sort of
160 right pan down please look
look at these onions first of all
flatten them in the pan
like that okay now watch very carefully
this is really important
take a little teaspoon okay of sugar
and just caramelize with the sugar in
there
put a little touch of salt over there
okay just a touch
okay from there a little bit of butter
and what's gonna happen now with these
onions they get really nice
and sweet and caramelized but
watch what happens when that sugar
starts to caramelize it's a sweet red
onion so
it's incredible flavor they cook
instantly and they're nowhere near
as acidic okay as the white onion
now i much prefer using red onion and i
do with shallots because the flavor
is incredible now this is where the
magic starts to happen
gas is on full fast food vinegar pan
down please
balsamic vinegar just over now look at
the color of the onions
that intensifies the caramelization
gives a little bit of acidity
but a really nice sweet way now look at
those onions pan down please pan down
i'm down good now this is where the
magic comes in look
a little bit worcester sauce okay again
just glaze over those onions
now what happens here it gives the
onions a very dark note
and it almost gives a sort of really
nice sort of sour
sort of rich flavor pan down please pan
down pan down
now it's gone yeah halfway basically
thank you for the encouragement
now look from there keep those onions
flat in the pan like that they'll
caramelize ten times quicker but more
importantly
the sugar the lean paring and the
vinegar is making this wonderful caramel
okay now look at the potatoes
don't have been on for three minutes pan
down please come on
take that in take a little square out
put it between your fingers
and push it and look it's still a little
bit firm in there so that's about one
minute away
now once you reduce the vinegar
reduce the limb carry but just come into
the pan again tilly come into the pan
see it from up here they need to see it
i guess need to see it
they can see it look at the color of
that though look
is that beautiful hello i'm talking to
you tilly i'm sorry yes it's beautiful
thank you all you want is compliments
a little touch of stock you can use
vegeta chicken stock beef stock
don't flood the pan just about four
tablespoons of stuff
let that reduce down now bring that up
to the boil
check the potatoes again again i cut
them into dice
and look that's soft all the way through
now here's the secret
the colander off
now drain them put your pan back on
there
i'm not using butter in my mash i'm
going to use olive oil
okay give them a really good shake
okay dry out the pan
please follow me on this one because
it's really important okay back in there
you'll say why are you doing that why
are you doing that thank you because
it's making them fluffy
okay that's really important no
it's not listen okay i'm just saying
what you talk i know no but i mean how
many times i've made mashed potatoes for
you
lots of times right dad everyone's
saying i'm doing a good job on the
camera too
stop telling me what to do okay look
look in now look in please
so masha okay no ricer and in on the
heat
okay now what happens now is the
potatoes getting really
nice and fluffy pan down please pan down
down
and then look if you do this hot we'll
get them super fine
again back off the heat now look this is
where they go up to another level
look how fluffy they are look how fluffy
that is
down down down down down back onto the
heat
okay really important now
a little glug of olive oil and i want
you to beat that in there now
okay and look look what's happening
come back down please got to come back
down
so no butter just olive oil in there and
eight minutes yes okay maybe two minutes
look now just look how rich just look
look look at that beautiful but i'm not
done down with the gas
some smoked salt in there just a touch a
little bit of mustard in there okay
yeah just a touch and then from there
take the fresh chives that's going to
give you a really nice lift
and make this mashed potato so delicious
it absolutely lifts it go one minute
yes i've made mashed potatoes for you
hundreds of times just look at that
smoothness and look
look that is beautiful come on pan in
pan into my mash
okay off with the gas now just taste
taste that okay take your time and tell
what you think
take your time i am taking my time don't
rush it
see dab yes that's good but
white heat page 66 marco pierro white
the naked chef page 21 jamie oliver
delia smith learned to cook
page 80. now all those books have one
thing in common
and those page numbers the best
best mashed potato recipes out there
dad you only got 30 seconds left when
you've gone
really wait seriously i'm telling you go
look for those recipes
and you will not regret it that's unfair
favorite match ever what you just did
there
come back down here this place i've put
a small knob of butter in there sausages
check out
look dad 10 seconds to go okay okay okay
but watch
i'm watching try and get a nice
beautiful curve of mash that mustard
is so fragrant dad i hate to say this
but um
wait wait wait wait wait in 10 minutes
you're over wait wait look at that
look at that come on please i mean
sausages i'll give you a bit of extra
time wait wait wait
wait wait wait mommy didn't make it in
10 minutes on
[Music]
on now i can't believe you just said
those stats
i said from there look
a little another butter in those
caramelized onions
and then you just generously look
you see it those seconds on top
come on that is a smash
done in 10 minutes and 57 seconds
have a great weekend continue show me
all
your bangers and mash god bless you